rudy giuliani is suspended from the
practice of law
indefinitely he hasn't been disbarred
yet but that
may be coming the new york bar has found
that rudy giuliani has violated
many of his ethical obligations as a
lawyer especially with respect to
being truthful and honest in front of
tribunals they have found that there is
incontrovertible evidence that he
in fact lied to countless numbers of
courts and individuals with respect to
the
2020 election as we've talked about a
lot on this channel lawyers have to be
truthful they cannot lie in furtherance
of their clients aims and the new york
courts found that rudy lied with respect
to mail-in ballots in pennsylvania and
lied about a lot of the things that were
happening in georgia rudy argued that
this violates his first amendment rights
but that generally doesn't work when
you're talking about ethical violations
with respect to a profession in this
case the profession of practicing law
this is of course highly unusual but the
magnitude of the lies that rudy was
telling in front of lots of different
courts is also
extremely unusual so he is suspended
indefinitely pending further
investigation so we will definitely see
rudy in court to see if he is disbarred